to replace boris johnson before a first
round of voting by mps tomorrow the
rules are that they need at least 20 mps
to support them
two nominators and at least 18 others to
back them and
there is sig graham nominated uh in
alphabetical order uh kemi vadanok
proposed by lee rowley seconded by julia
lopez
serena braverman proposed by david jones
seconded by miriam cates
jeremy hunt
proposed by esther mcveigh and seconded
by anthony magnol
penny mordant
proposed by andrea ledson dave andrea
ledson and seconded by craig tracy
rishi sunak
proposed by dominic rabb
seconded by mel stride
liz truss
proposed by simon clark
seconded by therese coffee
tom tugandath proposed by anne-marie
trevelyan
seconded by james daly
and nadim zahawi proposed by brandon
lewis seconded by amanda milling those
eight will go to the first round uh
ballot uh tomorrow between 1 30 and 3 30
with the results announced
as soon as we can
after that
thank you
well short and sweet there from the
chairman of the 1922 committee there and
simply telling us those that will
proceed as you heard to graham say there
to the ballot of mps tomorrow all he
mentioned there was uh the proposers and
seconders and then that they have got at
least 18 other mps to support them the
actual numbers we do not know although
i'm sure we will fairly soon because
this is going to be a fairly leaky
leadership campaign let's go back to our
political editor beth rigby on that and
then there were eights well there there
were nine about 15 minutes ago but sajid
javid withdrew voluntarily
yeah and looking at that list um but it
might be that three i i could see three
of them that potentially just do not get
uh the numbers tomorrow to proceed uh to
the next round perhaps even four of them
we do know that mordent
uh
sunak and truss are the ones uh kind of
uh in the lead and then tom tuggenheart
of course who is the uh the favored
candidate of the liberal group within
the party the one uh nation
conservatives
but look this is going to get whittled
down very quickly we've got a ballot
tomorrow in the first result if you
don't get 30 votes or more you're out
and then there could be another ballot
the next day we could get to the final
two as early as monday next week
depending on how
it all shakes out but i really think
that now there's going to be quite a a
big fight on the hand
between penny morden and liz trust to
try and get into that final two
with rishi sunak
who looks at the moment pretty nailed on
as the clear front runner uh with mps
well let's uh talk more about reaction
within the heart of parliament in itself
uh sam kurtz our deputy political editor
is there in central lobby so sam
wherever you are wherever you're going
to appear in my screens down there i
suspect sam um what what are you hearing
what's the reaction to that
more or less as expected apart from the
late withdrawal of sajid javid
well i think the surprise in the last
few hours is that jeremy hunt managed to
get over the line there were genuine
questions i'm told that members of the
hunt campaign were desperately phoning
round estimate vay who he's promised to
be deputy prime minister in the event
that he pretty unlikely that it has to
be say does actually win uh phoning
around desperate to get their
candidacy their candidate the 20 names
necessary uh he is in the campaign
sergeant javid uh as you say looks like
he didn't get the numbers and has
therefore uh resigned therefore gone out
but it really is a contest that hinges
around the conversation about what's
going to happen to rishi sunak what's
going to happen to liz trust and what's
going to happen to penny morden and the
extent to which over the next few days
uh hours and days more of a stop rishi
campaign builds up because although
rishi like is undoubtedly dermot the
front runner uh in this contest with the
number uh of mps backing in him there is
clearly as we've been hearing uh from uh
people who are in boris johnson's
cabinet uh that they don't think that
he's fit
to take over the reigns from boris
johnson and that he should be stopped
from stopped from winning this contest
and i think therefore the conversation
that's going on is do most of penny
mordant's supporters are they prepared
to back liz trust could it be the other
way around
and what's going to happen to the vast
majority of the votes of the mps the
candidates that are standing who are not
going to
not going to make it this is a contest
based on people's second choice in
effect and one of the things that's
going on behind the scenes here quite
important we've seen some of the public
launches of the campaigns but one of the
things that's really driving the dynamic
mps tell me are some of the private
hustings that have been going on now
last night there's a brexiteer group the
erg held their own private hustings and
it was at that i'm told that liz trust
came across as a firm uh on issues of
the northern ireland protocol and uh
issues like that prime ministerial was
the word one person who was at that
hustings uh said that she came across
whereas rishi sunak just didn't quite
look like he could always fill a room he
could be a little touchy as he was at
points in that launch this morning and i
think those things are massively
weighing on the views of mps
as they try and weigh up who to back
and so those private hustings more of
which they're going to be very soon
actually playing a big role in this uh
otherwise public debate
okay let's get the views on that list of
katie balls deputy political editor with
a spectator uh so katie do you think
that uh this list is going to be
whittled down fairly soon and coalesce
around the uh stop rishi and team rishi
strands
yeah i mean i just think the timetable
means it's inevitable but when we're
looking at what's going to happen i
think it seems very likely obviously in
politics there's always surprises that
rishi said it's on course for one of the
final two spots i think it probably
helps he has
plenty of former whips such as gavin
williams and on his team now who we know
a good campaign is good with the numbers
and they'll be helping him with the next
stages but then also i think now we're
seeing the fight on the right and in the
early days of this contest there were
several candidates vying to be the
candidate and lots of warnings saying
well actually the mps on the right of
the party need to get around one
candidate otherwise they risk a
situation where they don't really have
someone representing their views um and
i think we're starting to see liz trust
emerges that with jacob rees-mogg the
dean doris endorsements today suggesting
despite the fact she voted to remain she
is as much a brexiteer as jacob
rees-mogg now i think jacob rees-monk's
anti-rishi sunac sentiment is probably
helping him get there um to a degree
but can she continue that in which case
i think you're starting to look at a
potential final two and but as we said
penny morden is still doing uh well in
terms of numbers but i think if the
right can coalesce around a candidate
that is going to make it harder for
penny moderns
kt many thanks for that katie balls
there from the spectator our political
editor beth rigby is with me beth let's
talk about the mps are going to do the
voting tomorrow it's always said that
they don't necessarily vote for the
candidate they want certainly in the
first round sometimes they vote for a
candidate from the other side to knock
down you know i mean it's it's so
complex it's like it's the hall street
cloak and daggers now um
and you are absolutely right and one
thing that really will help rishi sinha
because as kate was just saying that he
has on his bench now the swot team in
the parliamentary party of whips and
counters grant shaps the keeper of the
list i mean he was predicting uh votes
for for boris johnson uh into you know
to precision points uh and the
confidence vote i mean he's very good at
spreadsheets so he's handy typing team
and gavin williamson and mark spencer
and mark harper
but also as you said once you have a big
group of mps
you then can vote tactically to get them
to lend votes to other candidates to
knock other people out and that is what
you see now in the last leadership race
uh when it was boris johnson jeremy hunt
and michael gove you remember
the revenge there from the johnson camp
uh hunt won by one vote knocking michael
do you remember knocking michael gove
out by one vote now that's my memory i
hope it's not failing me now i'm
stouting myself grant chaps but the
point was um the point was
was that it was better
in their view to have hunt in the final
than than gov because hunt was a
remainer that had that now wanted brexit
but a soft brexit and and johnson was
the true brexiteer right and so so what
you might see now is rishi's team if
they get the kind of momentum
he's got i just checked he's got 45
public backers against 26 for more than
21 for trust
whether they take a decision that
actually trusts is more beatable in the
final two uh the mordant and then do
they start the skull duggary i mean i
can't keep up with that
mess what can go wrong with a strategy
like that but uh sam coats has we said
well precisely sam coates is in the
heart of the political calderon there in
central lobby and uh you've got some
reaction sam
cauldron it certainly is yes i'm here
with andrew mitchell he's one of the
prominent backers of jeremy hunt who to
the surprise of some actually managed to
get on the ballot got those 20 uh votes
and nominations earlier today
potentially at the cost of saving javid
um mr mitchell
how close to how close was it for jeremy
hunt to be ejected oh i don't think we
ever had any any doubts at all that he
would make it onto the ballot paper the
question is what happens next and
i think some very good candidates have
made it and tomorrow we will see what
happens in the next round
but there were
people talking about jeremy hunt s
mcveigh wandering around desperately
making calls at the last minute
you say that you always had the votes i
think i think that the opposite is the
case actually i think that many
colleagues believe there are three key
criteria uh that are required to win
this campaign the first is to be
unsullied by the recent boris times the
second is to be experienced preferably
with a domestic as well as an
international department and the third
is to be moral and i think it's true to
say that many of the candidates hit two
of those three criteria but only jeremy
hunt hits all three
but
can we really looking at the numbers for
all the candidates can you really say
that being unsullied is the quality that
people want given the vast numbers 45
who are back publicly backing rishi soon
given the vast numbers uh that are
backing uh penny morden and liz trust if
mps are willing to put their first
preference votes for those really not
being in government doesn't matter too
much to
the mps certainly well i think i think
there's two points to that uh the first
is that the key thing my colleagues want
to do is win the next election we want
to ensure there isn't a socialist
government the question is who is best
placed to win that battle i think that
jeremy hunt is undoubtedly best placed
because he's not solid in that way and
you know all the other candidates have
virtues but i'm just trying to explain
to you why i think he is the right man
to become prime minister now for those
three reasons and to take us forward
tackle the extraordinary problems which
face us and win the next election there
are some candidates like yours like tom
tugan hat who want to draw a line
between a thick line between the boris
johnson regime and the kind of
premiership they would offer but again
it looks like there are plenty of
candidates that are prepared to be
continued continuity boris johnson liz
trust
amongst that do you actually think that
promising to change direction is a
selling point right now i mean we have
to completely change the tone and
character of the government i mean just
look at the polling look at what
happened in the by-elections look at the
research drawing a line under the last
couple of years is absolutely essential
and uh all the candidates i'm sure will
draw that to some extent but jeremy
preeminently marks a change and that is
a change we require if we're to hold our
constituencies and win the next election
so the next hurdle tomorrow uh you need
to get 30 mps where where are you going
to draw your uh support from are you
talking to supporters of sadhu javid who
who dropped out where are you going to
get the necessary numbers for tomorrow i
think we draw our support from across
the party you've got a strong alliance
between jeremy and esther north south
man woman liberal democrat facing
labor-facing
pro-brexit
we're all past brexit now the reason i
voted for boris johnson on the last
occasion was i believe the country had
to be led so well for everyone yeah for
so much braverman's campaign doesn't
seem to be past brexit liz trust is
playing up her brexit credentials are
you sure you called that right yes
because that was why i voted for boris
last time we had to be led by a
brexiteer but we are through brexit now
and i think it is a lesser issue the key
issue facing the country is what we do
about this terrible cost of living
crisis the extraordinary international
position in europe with the war in
ukraine it's what we do in britain for
our constituents faced with a
conglomeration of difficulties which we
frankly haven't seen in this country for
many years final question do you think
this
this contest is desperately edifying you
can see nadine doris jacob rees-mogg
taking slugs out of the former
chancellor are you proud to be a
conservative right now i'm very proud of
the fact that jeremy hunt's campaign
there will be no attacks on any other
campaign jeremy made it clear that if
anyone on his campaign attacked one of
the other campaigns they will be
straight off it we are fighting an
absolutely clean campaign and the key
criteria is how do we tackle these
extraordinary crises how do we win the
next election in my opinion jeremy is
the man
andrew mitchell thank you very much
indeed yes for some it has not been the
most edifying of few days there are even
some supporters of liz trust in the
cabinet worried
about the attacks by nadine doris by
jacob rees-mogg on rishi sunak so many
people are saying after this contest
which concludes on september the 5th
they've got to put the party back
together again the basis of today and
yesterday that's looking like an
order
okay sam many thanks for that i deputy
political editor sam coats there well
joining me now is the conservative mp
for north dorset simon hor he's backing
rishi sunax bid to become prime minister
very good to see you mr hall well let me
put um that point that sam goats was
making there about to the attack on
rishi sonic by jacob reese morgan nadine
doris and you'll be aware of the charge
that he's putting up taxes jacob
rees-mogg perhaps even called him a
socialist and uh that he was plotting
while he was sitting there with boris
johnson at his right hand plotting
against him well i mean directly what
andrew mitchell was saying about jeremy
hunt's campaign i think russia's been
very clear he wants this to be a
positive campaign about a vision of
values and commitment to the world those
charges have been made in public i i
think they will ring hollow uh frankly
if anybody was concerned with regards to
what the government was doing
they could have resigned and spoken out
voted against the uh increases on say
for example national insurance
contributions uh but they didn't so i
think this is sort of slightly trying to
shut the stable door after the horse has
bolted i don't recall recall any of
those people who now seem to be making
the most enormous fuss about these tax
rises having done so when they were
going through and the choice was and
it's worthwhile just reminding ourselves
why did we feel it was important to
raise national insurance contributions
it was order to ensure that we didn't
have as constituency members of
parliament
long backlogs of people at our advice
surgeries saying that they couldn't get
medical surgery because of the backlog
obviously created by kovid and i think
this speaks to a good story of rishi
sunak when a time when a lot of people
say the tory party is ideological if you
look at what he did with regards to nic
if you look at what he did with regards
to
further and the support he gave to
business and to employees this was not
an ideological chancellor this was a
chance of being pragmatic
it doesn't seem to be mentioned at all
in terms of his back catalogue so to
speak um you know what went on during
the long pandemic and that i mean it was
it was you know i'm saying this without
fear or favor without partisanship it
was applauded the speed of that reaction
as well how the treasury got it right i
think but he's getting no credit for
that well i think he will as people
reflect upon it i mean you know
so much of this now seems to be quite
ancient history but an ideological
chancellor an ideological cabinet would
have turned around and said well just
let the markets decide businesses will
succeed if they want to succeed and will
fail if they're going to fail he said no
we have to look to a post-coveted
economy and try and make sure that we're
in best place i agree with you i think
people have short memories
what we're going to see i hope over the
next coming days coming weeks i'd like
to see rishi into the final two before
party members uh through the summer is a
reminder
yeah
okay that's the memory and to show the
energy the pedestrian engagement
about this contest that this is the
conservative party talking to itself
initially the mps and then to the
membership and it is ideological and
there's a lot of talk about the memory
of margaret thatcher and tax cuts just
looming so so large
into this debate early on
you say talking to itself i thought what
i was struck by and you could say well
simon hang on you're supporting brushy
so you're about to say nice things about
him but i think what i was struck with
by what he said this morning at his
campaign launch was
he's going to avoid the trap of just
talking to the conservative party this
has got to be the conservative party and
future leaders of the conservative party
talking to the country as well because
we're not electing just a leader we're
electing somebody who's going to take
the race as prime minister and i think
he's fundamentally engaged in that he
comes from a good so as part of that
democratic process could i push it along
a bit if he were to win would he hold a
general election fairly soon because he
hasn't been elected by the british
people well he has in his constituency i
know how it works sure but he has not
been endorsed as prime minister by the
british
it's a fair question and i in honestly
don't know what his thinking is on that
my hunch would be i mean
get hold of you know brenda from bristol
first and let her box your ears before
before she boxes mine
i think given the scale of the pressures
that we have
inflation uh pressures with regards to
the cost of living stuff going on the
horrors going on in ukraine and
everything else i'm not certain that the
electorate at large would go do you know
what we need do you know what we really
need now to solve all of these problems
and to address our issues and concerns
it's a six-week general election
campaign i think they're fed up of the
process of politics if you will and
we've had too much of this over the last
few months of trying to shore this
person up or sure the prime minister up
or whatever it may happen to be i think
people now have a very legitimate clamor
very legitimate appetite to see
politicians actually doing the job that
we're paid to do which is to take
decisions some of them will be difficult
i know but to take decisions in good
faith to the betterment of the country
and a general election campaign is the
last thing people will want to say i'm
sure very good to see simon oh supporter
as you heard there of rishi sunakanda
there are the contenders minus it must
be said sajid javid and grant
some of those who initially went into
that contest this morning how quickly
things have changed there you go we're
making it very clear the ins and outs
they're eight left uh beth rigby our
political editor is here with me right
now eight left and we're
thinking that certainly there's one or
two there who may well find themselves
not there this time tomorrow night yeah
look going in going into today cersei
nadim zahawi and jeremy hunt
were in sort of the mid teens so jeremy
hunt was on 15 nadeem saharwi was on 14
they've got over
the line this evening but there has to
be questions about whether or not they
can continue through uh beyond that
but also just just out as we've been
talking on this matter of kind of the
infighting and the stop rishi
campaign
nadine doris uh saying uh in a tweet
that there are dirty tricks of stitch up
dark hearts take your pick team rishi
want the candidate they know they can
definitely beat in the final two and
that is jeremy hunt and that was on uh
suggestions that uh someone's suggesting
telling journalists that um gavin
williamson had organized some siphoning
off of some votes to let jeremy hunt get
over the thresholds that was from dan
dan hodge is there
what's interesting in nadine dory's
tweeting that
is
when i interviewed when i grabbed jacob
rees-mogg earlier if he had private
personal animosity uh towards rishi
sanak he was not openly saying that when
we spoke so that was behind closed doors
if that is how he feels he was sort of
saying i'm not backing rishi because of
policy differences now he did take a
little dig at him but it wasn't as avert
as nadine dori's uh there and and of
course nadine doris that's completely
her prerogative to do
but politically what some people in
rival camps have suggested to me
is that for liz truss if there is such
aggressive briefing against sonak from
those in the trust camp does it turn
other mps off her camp because actually
everyone is publicly saying we want to
fight a clean campaign what the
parliamentary party doesn't want to do
beyond this leadership race is continue
with these divisions that are basically
driving the party apart driven boris
johnson out of number 10. but most
importantly if you're a conservative mp
driven your polling down uh with members
of the public um so it's it's
interesting to see kind of how this
plays out in the coming days and and how
aggressive different teams become to
each other openly uh as we get down to
the final uh final end of the bat but i
have to say as you were saying uh for
jeremy hunt uh it's gonna be very hard
for rishi sanak's team to kind of propel
jerry hunt into to the final two i mean
rishi sanat would need a hell of a lot
of votes uh to be able to control that
and the danger is if you're going to
lend your votes out so to speak as that
theory goes yeah then you begin to lose
momentum in in the public eye yeah you
know he's your campaign favorite and and
bar response was like a runaway train i
did actually look back it wasn't one
vote that jeremy hunt beat gave bite was
two but but boris johnson had like 160
and then they were in the 70s and that's
the thing like rishi sunuk at the moment
uh doesn't have this massive gap between
him and and the others but let's see how
the cards fold and then who comes into
his deck uh as we go along in the next
four checkouts i'm really interested to
see where sergeant javid goes for a
start yeah and it'd be really
interesting to see what the actual uh
numbers were all we got from graham
brady was the fact that that those
candidates were through to voting
tomorrow
plenty more on that coming up you're
watching the newshour at six uh also
coming up
another bad day for england's white
ballside as they're beaten by ten
wickets of the oval by india
[Music]
and obviously with the weather it's
really really important that we monitor
it and monitor our animals really really
careful